AND THIS BRINGS IN A NEW BREED
OF SURFER FROM AUSTRALIA.
THEY WIN A BUNCH
OF COMPETITIONS.
THEN THEY [bleep] GET
IN THE PRESS
AND THEY INSULT
HAWAIIAN CULTURE,
SAYING, HAWAIIAN WAY
OF SURFING IS OLD.
IT'S OUT OF DATE.
WE'RE THE FUTURE.
WE'RE THE FUTURE OF SURFING.
I DATED AN AUSTRALIAN
FOR TWO YEARS.
CAN'T DO AN AUSTRALIAN ACCENT.
I THANK GOD,
BECAUSE I'D DO IT ALL THE TIME.
THE HAWAIIANS
ARE REASONABLE PEOPLE,
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN
PUSHED TO THE POINT.
SO THE AUSTRALIANS
GET BEAT UP A FEW TIMES.
PROBABLY MADE THEM
BETTER PEOPLE.
AT A CERTAIN POINT,
THEY'VE GOTTEN BEAT UP SO MUCH
THAT THEY'RE, LIKE, HOLED UP
IN THEIR ROOM.
THERE'S A KNOCK ON THE DOOR.
KNOCK, KNOCK, KNOCK.
AND THEY'RE JUST LIKE,
OH, NO.
SO THEY GRAB A BUNCH
OF TENNIS RACKETS.
RABBIT GRABS THE DOORKNOB
AND HE TURNS IT LIKE,
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN?
HE OPENS IT UP,
AND IT'S EDDIE.
AND HE'S LIKE, HEY.
I DON'T HAVE A TENNIS RACKET.
PLEASE PUT THOSE AWAY.
ALSO, WHY DO YOU HAVE SO MANY?
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
EDDIE WALKS THEM TO A HOTEL
WITH A CONFERENCE ROOM.
AND EDDIE'S LIKE,
WHAT YOU'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
HAS BEEN HAPPENING
ON THESE ISLANDS FOR SO LONG,
WHERE WHITE PEOPLE
ARE JUST SAYING, LIKE,
HAWAIIANS,
YOUR CULTURE'S NOT REAL.
IT'S ALL BULL[bleep].
WE RECOGNIZE YOU SURF WELL,
BUT YOU'RE BEING
A [bleep] DICK.
ALL OF YOU ARE A GROUP
OF PENISES SITTING HERE.
AFTER A WHILE,
THE AUSTRALIANS ARE LIKE,
WE DON'T WANT TO BE DICKS.
WE WANT TO BE COOL
SURFER DUDES.
WE'RE SO SORRY.
DO YOU KNOW THEY SAY
"WIDE ON" FOR A FEMALE BONER?
THAT'S AN AUSTRALIAN TERM.
AS OPPOSED TO A HARD ON,
IT'S A WIDE ON.
DON'T YOU MAKE ME
EXPLAIN THIS MORE.